on va aller plus loin avec notre invité
qui nous a rejoint son se paie ton
gérald olivier bonsoir vous êtes
journaliste franco américain chercheur à
l'institut de prospective et de sécurité
en europe thomas venait d'en parler
cette petite sieste ans dont on a vu les
photos un petit peu partout sur internet
au moment où une personne d'ailleurs sur
scène à un précisé justement
l'importance de prendre des décisions
sur le climat voilà on peut y voir une
métaphore de la triste réalité le
décalage souvent entre les discours des
chefs d'état est là et la réalité oui
pour nivoix au sida dis donc qu'est
fatigués quelques un petit peu âgées et
puis une certaine somme moyens étaient
longs voyages et lots ou les fins voyage
remonte à jeudi il a eu lie d'arriver à
rome où wade a pas mal d'activités non
mais ça tombe très mal votre reporter a
parfaitement raison votre correspondant
à washington a parfaitement raison c'est
une c'est une image qui a été reprise
par les réseaux sociaux parce qu'elle
fait sourire alors elle fait son nez
d'autant plus que pour joe biden ce
sommet était très important il faut
rappeler qu'il l'a préparé il l'a
préparée au mois d'avril et encore une
fois votre journaliste à washington
avait raison de rappeler qu'il aurait
beaucoup voulu venir avec des munitions
et ses munitions c'était ces fameuses
enfin les deux lois qui sont en attente
est en discussion devant le congrès
parce que dans ces lois il y à un
certain nombre de fêtes qu'il va d'un
certain nombre de choses qui vont venir
pour justement participer à la
transition énergétique américaine et a
priori diminuer leur empreinte carbone
et augmenter leur recours aux énergies
non fossiles
or il est il est venu les mains vides et
il s'endort pour la journée d'ouverture
dont l'image est pas très bonne alors
effectivement un job and higher qui
s'exprime en ce moment même qui a
dévoilé une série de réglementations
vivement vide en visant pardon à à
réduire nettement les émissions de
méthane de l'industrie pétrolière et
gazière aux états unis mais les états
unis c'est toujours la même question à
ce qu'ils sont vraiment prêts à sortir
de cette dépendance de l'énergie fossile
et du pétrole en tout cas en tout cas
est ce qu'ils sont prêts alors il ya
deux façons de répondre est ce que je
dis idéologiquement ou émotionnellement
est ce qu'ils sont prêts ce que
techniquement ils le sont il n'y aurait
pas la même réponse actuellement le
renouvelable c'est 12 % de
l'approvisionnement énergétique
américain le solaire
en pourcent et l'éolien propre sens et
donc on est alors que 67% c'est du
fossile donc remplacer deux tiers votre
approvisionnement énergétique pas
quelque chose qui pour l'instant
totalise 4 % votre approvisionnement
c'est pas du tout évident à faire du
jour au lendemain donc sur ce point de
vue là il est évident qu'ils ne sont pas
prêts ensuite les états unis sont une
puissance en matière d'énergies fossiles
et sacrifié cette puissance sans savoir
ce qu'il y aura derrière c'est quelque
chose qui politiquement est beaucoup
plus difficile à faire très
politiquement on en parlait d'ailleurs
tout à l'heure mais thomas en attendant
effectivement comment il perçu ce ce
rendez-vous de la coop 26 aux états unis
comme l'a bien décrit gérald olivier
c'est vrai que mentalement et
techniquement les états unis sont pas
forcément prêts à sortir de leurs leurs
vieilles dépendance si j'ose dire
oui c'est d'ailleurs un peu l'opposition
qui faisait déjà fois lors de la
campagne présidentielle entre joe biden
et donald trump puisque la question des
emplois liés à ces énergies fossiles et
est souvent abordée par donald trump à
vous avez entendu tout à l'heure
l'ancien président américain qui parlait
aux travailleurs de pennsylvanie on sait
que c'est un état où il ya une
production de pétrole notamment mais
vous avez d'autres états comme la
virginie occidentale qui est très riche
en charbon et le sénateur qui bloque
aujourd'hui l'adoption au congrès du
plan d'investissement sur le
réchauffement climatique notamment de
joe biden c'est le sénateur john en
chine il est élu en virginie occidentale
et s'il refuse notamment d'adopter ce
plan c'est parce qu'il sait que cela
pourra avoir un impact sur l'économie de
l'état dans lequel il est élu et donc il
ya toujours cette question des emplois
qui est mise en parallèle avec la
question évidemment de l'écologie même
si on sent qu'il ya une progression dans
l'opinion de l'importance accordée à ces
questions puisque des récents sondages
montraient que désormais elle 59% des
américains interrogés considéré comme
très important la lutte contre le
dérèglement climatique alors qu'en 2018
seuls 49% des américains se disaient
très soucieux de cette question les gens
de viviez vous le disiez donc
blocage aussi sur le plan évidemment
politique qui suit les mentalités
américaines les républicains qui
bloquent souvent on l'a dit tout à
l'heure mais aussi parfois les
démocrates oui oui mais c'est bien la
question et va encore une fois votre
votre journaliste parfaitement résumé la
situation
aujourd'hui les démocrates ont la
majorité à la chambre des représentants
s'il voulait voter cette loi ils
pourraient le faire demain à condition
d'avoir la garantie qu de tous voté dans
le même sens c'est pas le cas
aujourd'hui et en plus au sénat ils sont
à 50-50 avec les républicains et ils ont
deux sénateurs qui rechignent pour deux
raisons différentes à voter ce plan
monsieur monde chine pour les raisons
qui viennent d'être évoqués et madame
cinéma qui est sénatrice de l'arizona et
qui elles rechignent plus tôt sur le
point de vue des taxes qu'ils paient des
impôts qui inévitablement se livrer
cette loi est comme elle est dans un
état où les électeurs n'aiment pas
beaucoup payé des impôts eh bien elle ne
veut pas vous voter une loi qui
inévitablement va aller les augmenter
donc on a des discussions au sein même
du parti démocrate et les républicains
n'ont pas à être opposés à cette
législation parce que de toute façon
c'est le camp d'en face qui n'arrivent
pas à s'unir et tant qu'ils seront pas
unis ne se passera rien thomas est ce
que c'est populaire de lutter contre le
dérèglement climatique
aux etats unis c'est pas exactement la
première question parce que
effectivement il ya sept ce style de vie
américain qui est pas toujours en phase
vraiment avec l'environnement os et
oui de toute façon l'économie à une
place évidemment très importante pour
l'opinion américaine est dès lors que
des emplois risquent d'être menacés il y
a une position je lisais par exemple des
témoignages de syndicats de travailleurs
du charbon ou du pétrole qui explique
qu'ils aient bien par exemple il ya john
kerry qui demande à ses employés de
changer de voie peut être de se
reconvertir pour travailler pourquoi pas
dans la fabrication de panneaux solaires
et ses gens expliquent qu'ils n'ont pas
forcément l'envi de se reconvertir dans
d'autres secteurs et qu' il ya aussi
peut-être moins d'argent qui leur sera
accordé donc il ya un aspect économique
qui est très important d'ailleurs joe
biden qui est connaît très bien la
pennsylvanie avait beaucoup parlé de cet
aspect là lors de la dernière campagne
présidentielle pour tenter justement de
rassurer tous les travailleurs qui
aujourd'hui dépendent à 100% de
l'exploitation des ressources naturelles
des énergies fossiles mais il ya encore
beaucoup d'inquiétudes et ses
inquiétudes elles sont évidemment
majoritaire pour les personnes qui sont
concernées et plus globalement pour les
localités les états où sont basés les
exploitations de ressources fossiles
j'adore olivier quand je parlais du mode
de vie des américains c'est vrai que qui
a été aux états unis se rend compte est
toujours frappé les grosses voitures
individuelles la climatisation alors
aussi joe biden pousse dans le sens de
l'électrique m'enfin ils poussent pas
dans le sens des transports en commun
vont quand on connaît les intérêts us
est aussi très compliqué parfois de
faire en métro toutes ses distances mais
tout de même est ce que c'est compatible
avec ces grandes annonces oui plutôt
dépend d'où vient l'électricité
l'électricité peut très bien venir du
charbon donc même si quand on l'utilisé
à l'arrivée c'est non polluants au
départ ça reste peu le mans et ça reste
quelque chose qui émet des gaz de serre
il ya eu une petite évolution des
mentalités aux états unis a aussi une
évolution du style de vie américain qui
est quand même un tout petit peu moins
gaspilleur qui le fuit à une trentaine
ou une quarantaine d'années mais qui
reste quand même basé sur une
consommation assez je dirais peut
contrôler on va dire mais surtout ce qui
se passe aux etats unis c'est que même
si certains sont prêts à faire des
efforts pour la planète ils ne sont pas
prêts à sacrifier la prospérité
américaine pour sa 1 et 2 ils ne sont
pas prêts à faire des efforts si
d'autres ne le sont pas et rappelons qu
à glasgow nous avons la russie qui est
absente nous avons la chine qui est
absente en tout cas en terme de leurs
dirigeants principaux et nous avons
également le brésil qui est absent de la
russie qui a pris thème des
désengagements même titre que les autres
même et
c'est pas parce que c'est une chaîne
russe content mais il faut commencer ça
mais malgré tout la russie est une
économie qui dépend de ces énergies
fossiles qui dépend de son gaz naturel
et de son pétrole donc ça c'est un point
très important la chine c'est un pays
qui consomme énormément d'énergie
aujourd'hui et qui est le révélateur et
plus s'ils viennent ainsi que les états
unis voilà 27 % des émissions de co2
dans le monde proviennent de la chine
c'est deux fois et demie ce que les
etats-unis produisent aujourd'hui et
puis vous avez le brésil qui est le
premier en termes de déforestation et on
n'en parle pas assez de la déforestation
mais rappelons que les forêts servent
aussi à capter du co2 et que quand la
déforestation progresser bien en voix
inévitablement des température qui monte
des précipitations qui tombent une
désertification qui avancent donc c'est
un autre sujet dont on pourrait pour le
parler plus est au moins autant que des
émissions de gaz à effet de serre pour
conclure gérald olivier clairement pas
seulement un coup de communication ce
soir il y aura des actes selon vous suit
cette coop 26 alors c'est la deuxième
chose qui est très importante a remarqué
c'est que monsieur byden même président
des états unis peut faire un certain
nombre d' annonce à partir du moment où
il ya un finance un financement derrière
c'est le congrès qui contrôlent donc il
a promis par exemple de débloquer 3
milliards de dollars tous les ans pour
les pays africains pour compenser leurs
pertes dans la transition énergétique
mais si le congrès n'est pas de son côté
et si le congrès ne signe pas pour
libérer les fonds il pourra pas les
donner donc il ya une limite à ce que le
président américain peut annoncer
bientôt m'a d'ailleurs nous expliquer
combien il était parfois compliqué de
négocier au congrès merci thomas bonnin
en direct de washington merci n'avoue
gérald olivier sur ce plateau d'avoir
été avec nous aujourd'hui maire